good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight in July of 1993 a radio
station on kilgali Rwanda began openly
attacking one of the country's main
ethnic groups the Tutsis the radio
station was called rtlm but many
remember it as simply who to radio
because its audience was primarily Hutu
according to Hutu radio Tutsi people
were responsible for virtually every bad
thing that ever happened in Rwanda
tootsies had way too much money they had
way too much power tootsies were way too
privileged they were greedy they were
bigoted they were racists they were
dangerous everything about tootsiness
was repulsive
for the most part actual tootsies in
Rwanda ignored all of this Hutu radio
was not aimed at them
but then in July of 1994 just nine
months after rtlm went on the air a
genocide began in Rwanda more than half
a million Tutsis were murdered in many
cases by hutus whose rage had been
stoked to Violence by rtlm's broadcasts
entire Tutsi families were dragged from
their homes and hacked to death with
machetes hundreds of thousands of women
were raped
the world watched in horror as it
happened but did nothing to intervene
instead our leaders told us at the time
the genocide in Rwanda would live
forever as a lesson to the rest of us
about the capacity for evil that lurks
inside every human heart and the dangers
of reducing our neighbors to the sum
total of their ethnicity their
individuals not ethnic groups
Bill Clinton gave an eloquent speech
actually on the subject in kilgali back
in 1998. look it up
and ask yourself as you read it if any
Democratic Party official could today
say those same words
it's hard to imagine given what plays on
a loop on that party's cable news arm
MSNBC
have you watched MSNBC lately
likely you haven't like the tootsies
you're not the target audience but you
should tune in sometime
it's remarkable given that opposing
racism is America's natural religion
it may surprise you to learn that open
race hate forms much of the substance of
that Channel's programming and when we
say race hate we're not referring to
these subtle coded variety you want
border security you're giving your kids
piano lessons you like Shakespeare you
believe in the s.a.t you must be a
racist
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the kind of race
hate you cannot mistake for anything
else the kind of people just come out
and announce I hate this race of people
and here's why I do
it's hard to believe that anything like
that is happening right now on American
television but it is out in the open
and the most amazing and the most creepy
part of all is that no one is saying
anything about it it's all but ignored
and honestly we had no idea it was going
on either until we started getting texts
from people are you watching this can
you believe this
so we tuned in
apparently on the left what you're about
to see is considered completely normal
even good
and that should worry you deeply you
don't want to live in Rwanda
but in MSNBC they're already there now
you probably knew about Joy Reed the
race lady who's been fixated on Race
hate for years now but MSNBC has a new
host someone called Tiffany cross who
hosts a show called The Cross connection
here's a selection
many of us have seen the dangers when
powerful white people decide they want
something they Annex it and they've
never had a problem replacing the people
who stand in their way we see American
white people are going crazy they're
going they're resorting to violence this
is literally what conservative white
folks do when they don't get their way
they turn violent the white people
deputizing themselves in some position
of authority to have jurisdiction over
their life when they need to mind their
blanking business I don't think it's our
responsibility to be tasked with
destroying and dismantling the racial
oppression that's against us that's just
saying we're more at fault than the
white people who constructed this system
and the white people who continue to
practice institutional racism a majority
of white people do not support policies
that would unpack and unroll and reform
this system of justice this is what they
want Matt Gates is giving the white
folks what they want white replacement
can strangle culture so so yes we should
all be concerned about white replacement
it is after all a very threat to our
survival here
is there anything worse than white
people they're violent they're heartless
they're cruel they're deranged they're
secretive they're dishonest in fact as
you just heard Tiffany cross say white
people are a mortal danger to you and
your loved ones they threaten your life
are they poisoning the wells are they
baking bread with the blood of your
children if not according to Tiffany
cross and MSNBC they're fully capable of
doing those things they've certainly
done worse this is Hutu radio
but it's not an independent radio
station an African country it's part of
one of the biggest news organizations in
the world part of the biggest
telecommunications company in the United
States Comcast which owns it
so you have to ask yourself what is
Comcast board think of this Comcast
board is mostly white people white
people who according to the channel they
own decided they wanted something then
they annexed it white people who steal
because they're white white people could
quote turn to violence where they don't
get their way
white people are going crazy endangering
their communities
so you have to ask yourself why are they
putting this on the air why are they
allowing this this is not a policy
debate these are open attacks on people
on Americans on the basis purely of
their race and that's just a selection
we could go on and on and on are they
aware that this is happening perhaps
they're not we weren't to be fair
but it is happening day after day after
day after day at a certain point you
have to ask yourself if it continues and
nobody stops it
do they agree with it
maybe they do and just in case you think
that we are taking Tiffany cross out of
context and pulling the worst quotes
from a out of context segment to make
her seem crazy and racist
here's more here's Tiffany cross at
MSNBC
look a lot of folks in that Capital
Insurrection some of these folks were
white women and I know we're talking a
lot about Oath Keepers and proud boys
but I do think that some of the white
women who adopted have adopted this
ideology is America ready to face the
fact that some of those folks look like
people they have elevated and put on a
pedestal of being Untouchable what do
you say about this wing of of white
women who have been radicalized and are
enablers to this very dangerous domestic
terrorism movement that we've seen
increase quite rapidly
so it's not just whites it's white women
they're women are bad too
women of course are the key to
reproducing the white race which is
clearly a threat as she says again and
again to you and your family they're
dangerous they want to hurt you
now don't be fooled by the fact that
Tiffany cross can barely speak a
coherent sentence she was a
Communications major apparently
according to the internet that didn't
work but the gist of it is very very
clear white women are dangerous because
white people are dangerous they are
but the nature of their DNA potential
domestic terrorists
now you can play the game well if any
other group were spoken about this way
this would be shut down immediately and
of course that's completely true there
was no other group in America you could
talk about the way that Tiffany cross
and Joy Reid and other anchors in MSNBC
talk about white people
but he didn't even have to play that
game it doesn't matter what the color is
it's always wrong to reduce people
to the color of their skin to their
melanin content to their DNA and it's
even worse to attack them on the basis
of that and in fact it's the basis of
violence actual violence actual violence
but Tiffany cross can't be criticized
because she's oppressed that's the key
watch this what we didn't see were
enough voices willing to point out the
deeper festering rot that's plagued this
nation since it was born people who
neither discovered nor built this land
have been led to believe that America is
theirs and theirs alone will this
democracy survive well a Yahoo news poll
says no but perhaps when you build a
nation on Stolen land with stolen labor
it was never going to be a republic we
could keep and so here we are
celebrating The Birth of a Nation
Independence for white men
okay once again
calling out a specific Race by name now
you have to wonder what the other
anchors on MSNBC MSNBC some of whom are
that race do they notice this do they
know what's happening on their channel
are they okay with this what do you
think happens if we continue to talk
this way you may not watch that channel
but some people do
what does this look like in a year or
five years or ten years what kind of
country do you live in will a country at
war with itself race for
this woman Tiffany cross whose Clips
you've been watching is so deranged by a
racialist worldview that she believes
all people of one color are oppressed by
all people of another color and to prove
it she says even NFL players some of the
richest people in our society some of
the most celebrated the most famous the
most privileged even they can't escape
the all-pervasive hatred of diabolical
whites watch this
I gotta say Mike the Optics just look
bad to see all these black men crashing
into each other with a bunch of white
owners white coaches and the complete
disregard of black bodies and black life
I mean it just represents a larger issue
so I mean the average salary for an NFL
player is more than two million dollars
a year 60 of NFL players are
African-Americans in some positions like
cornerback virtually all the first
string players are black
so okay
we don't have a problem with that most
people don't have a problem with that
but if you look at that picture and say
this is white supremacy
what are you really saying you're saying
that anybody involved in the sport who
is white defiles the sport because
whiteness is itself inherently
corrupting white people are so evil that
their mere presence in a sport that is
overwhelmingly African-American and from
which African-American individuals are
benefiting is enough to destroy the
whole operation
because their whites involved
what kind of talk is that what's
genocidal talk actually not an
overstatement that's exactly what it is
so again you have to wonder what does
Comcast board think of this it's not a
rhetorical question really now that
we're talking about sports because
Comcast also owns an NHL team a hockey
team the Philadelphia Flyers and maybe
not surprising in the NHL just published
its first ever diversity report
and according to that report we have a
huge problem with hockey and the problem
is there are too many white people in
hockey now why is that a problem no one
actually explains it doesn't need to be
explained
because it's just Prima facial obvious
we've got a lot of white people that's
inherently bad because white people are
inherently bad again do you want to live
in a country where powerful people talk
this way what do you think it looks like
in five years
the head of
the NHL's quote social impact
division said quote we have a lot of
work to do
hmm
again how does Comcast board feel about
this will the board undergo some kind of
forced diversification what about the
NBA and the NFL admitting we're not
following all of this but is Joy reading
Tiffany cross tell us that's probably
because we're white and too stupid to
understand
I think for Kamala Harris she's had like
the triple problem of being a woman and
so people not being willing to respect
her the way that they would respect a
male vice president of being black which
we already know that what that carries
with it is the anti-blackness comes you
know with the package and then also
being vice president at a time that is
really really difficult so and I talk
about this all the time Madam vice
president and you know this Charlene see
black black okay she went to Howard she
AKA and when she talks to you yeah it is
I mean she sounds she's so regular she's
so regular she's really comfortable and
I just it's unfortunate that more people
don't see that and there's also just the
dumbing down of the American electorate
we could go on and on we could read
excerpts from Tiffany cross's book which
are brimming with racial hostility we
could play you a million clips from Joy
read which are exactly the same filled
with open racial hostility but you get
the point and if you don't believe it
just go ahead and tune in to MSNBC but
it's not really about that Channel or
those hosts it's about a society that
thinks that's oh okay
where it's not really about diversity
it's about hating other people on the
basis of their race and it's a little
bewildering to the rest of us who
thought the whole point of of America
was that we're aspiring to a country
where we are judged by the content of
our character not the color of our skin
and all of a sudden racial reductionists
don't simply have the floor
and the platform on cable news shows but
have apparently the unquestioning
support of the biggest
telecommunications company in the United
States what does that say about the
country and its leadership
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight